et venice dit en riant qu'elle était
invitée à chanter pendant les nuits de
fête
clarence blais mbaye tout d'abord on
vous retrouve à l'espace go ou vous êtes
vraiment une des têtes d'affiché de soif
matériaux mise en scène denis marleau
texte marie claire blais
rien de moins c'est quand même quelque
chose pour vous êtes en début de
carrière dans une aussi grosse
production comme envoyer ça j'avoue je
mets je me trouve baisse je me trouvais
ultra ultra chanceuse et privilégier gg
manque pas de me remplit toujours et
puis toulon est tellement agréable c'est
sûr que pour moi c'est comme c'est comme
un stage en accéléré j'apprends mais
j'apprends des gens super talentueux il
très rigoureux puis vraiment inspirant
et tellement gentil et généreux dans le
travail donc j'apprends j'apprends
beaucoup
bien sûr vous a vu plusieurs petits
rôles à la télévision et je pense dans
les honorables unités 9,38 euros
mais moi j'ai vraiment découvert au
théâtre dans les larmes amères de petra
dans le kent au théâtre prospero
vraiment j'avais remarqué que je compte
vous faire découvrir un autre public que
pour profiter à la base est une bonne
question mais en fait moi j'ai partagé
un parcours de musique classique et au
départ puis il ya eu un moment dans ma
jeune carrière de en tant qu bo east ou
et je me suis rendu compte qu'ils me qui
me manquait une dimension scénique je
pense que j'avais beaucoup d'énergie à
déployer en tant que artistes et que ça
ça pousse c'est très personnel je
sentais que une florence devait se
déployer plus sur scène puis qu'il y
avait quelque chose de la parole de
l'énergie du corps de la présence qui
qui devait
et c'est par là que ça devait s'exprimer
puis j'ai toujours eu une très grande
admiration pour les acteurs j'ai
d'ailleurs été négligé des ouvreuses au
tnm pendant 7 ans pendant l'été
pendant mes études au conservatoire de
musique de montréal puis je restais
toujours derrière il y avait les pleins
de production que je voyais comme treize
ou quatorze fois puis j'apprenais des
répliques par coeur puisque comme pour
se rendre compte que vous êtes peut-être
que cette requête a envie de 6,6 pas
juste quelque chose qui est m
un peuple qui ait envie d'en faire et
que lorsque votre sourire est contagieux
parce que vous avez vraiment demandé
metteur en scène veulent travailler avec
vous d'ailleurs vous aviez même pas
finir aux études que mathieu roy vous
embaucher pour son film l'autre maison
oui ça se passait et bien c'était tout
après ma première année au conservatoire
et j'ai su que mathieu roy mais ce qu'il
recherchait quelque chose de très précis
pour l'autre maison ils recherchaient
d'abord un rechercher un cast assez
précis c'est trop qu'elle me auxquels ou
et auxquels je correspondais et il
cherchait une musicienne actrice donc je
rentre entrait déjà dans quelque chose
d'assez d'acide pointu et c'était
vraiment c'était ma première audi
j'avais jamais j'avais jamais de tourner
au cinéma c'était ma première vraie
grosse audition pich peut-être que
j'étais ultra détendu parce que pour moi
ça me paraît tellement surréaliste que
j'ai ce rôle là que je fais comme ah
ouais on me demande pour ceux à qui
pourquoi protéger j'y vais et j'étais
c'était ultra ludique était vraiment
superbe et finalement je touchais un
état de jeu d'un coq que les
communiquerons quand on essaie de cogner
de retrouver à chaque fois en audition
lorsqu'on regarde l'ensemble de votre
carrière de comédienne musiciens
danseuses fait du yoga du vélo que
jamais vraiment toucher à tout hé bé oui
là où je me sens bien mais souvent je
les résumant en disant que je me sens
bien entre deux chaises c'est à dire que
j'ai
j'aurais de la misère à juste je pense
que je me serais pas senti complètement
accompli en et en faisant juste une
carrière de musicienne puis en faisant
juste une carrière d'actrice aussi je
pense que ça nous ça me prend ça me
prend les deux pour moi je jeu puis je
vois pas ça comme étant des affaires
séparées c'est juste des choses qu'une
florence envie de faire pour moi si
ultra c'est ultra de claire en fait ce
que je fais mais c'est vrai que c'est
parfois compliqué à expliquer aux gens
je la vends sol un bail
merci beaucoup merci à vous quelques
outils merci
[Musique]
on
oh si
[Musique]